which YouTube channels do I find most
inspirational this is a great question
and one that came in from Neil pull suck
pull shucks hopefully i pronounced that
properly everyone in heaven which
YouTube channels do you find most
inspirational and helpful now I am very
conscious with my time okay I hate waste
my time there's so much stuff on YouTube
and a lot of it is crap now I consume a
lot of YouTube channels but I'm very
careful about it so it's a great
question and I think you guys could
hopefully learn a lot about it and and
improve your education as well so I'm
going to load up the channels i have
here and talk a little bit about each
one so part of my process okay here's
two things that i do with youtube and
maybe you guys can learn from it in the
morning every morning i'll do a half an
hour run and when I'm running I'm
watching YouTube videos and these are
videos from people who inspire me who
make me think and I'm thinking about it
while I'm running I find when I'm moving
I I get ideas and I don't know it just
it just seeps in better than when I'm
just sitting in front of a desk so I
watch half an hour videos I'm active and
I get ideas for what I should do and get
inspired for my business in my life then
after that i'll have a shower and in my
shower I we should be thinking of what I
just watched so the YouTube videos are
really important for me in shaping how I
think you know you think that you are
the process and you're the result of of
the five people who you hang out with
for me it's also the people who i watch
because i feel like i watch these guys
so much that I kind of their my friends
and I hang out with them so I watch
every day almost youtube videos from
these guys and hopefully you can learn
from them so there are eight channels
that I subscribe to and I'll watch most
of the stuff that they put out I look
forward to it okay the first is behind
brand and that's by Brian Elliott and
this i discovered because i was i was
watching videos with gary vaynerchuk and
Seth Godin I love their stuff I wish
Seth had his own channel he basically
interviews people who are brand name and
he he just digs deep on them and they
give some great real honest advice for
entrepreneurs people have built a brand
for themselves and they want to to share
that and help other entrepreneurs do
something similar so I'm you know
building my brand up and I look up the
guys like Seth and Gary and so I've
recently this is my newest absque
ription maybe a day or two old and so
I'm still discovering all the great
stuff that that they have that offer but
it's called behind the brand bye bye
Brian Elliott the next one is Tim
Ferriss this was my first youtube
subscription now Tim doesn't do a lot on
YouTube he only does it every now and
then he he's the author of the four work
week my favorite book at the four-hour
shaft for our body and he's a lifehacker
and he finds ways to make your life
easier better more interesting and cuts
down the learning time on things and
helps you get to where you want to go
faster so some of his videos are
trailers for his books and promotions up
for what he's doing but the earlier
stuff was more about interesting things
that you can do in your life and so
again he doesn't post that often but I
love that channel was the first one to
subscribe to the next one is Hank Norman
Hank is is my agent and he almost never
posts he tweets a lot I almost never
post he preaches a lot about doing video
and I keep pressuring him to do video
but he's not doing it so follow Hank
Norman and say Hank we want more video
ok you can follow on Twitter you can
subscribe to his YouTube channel and
just bombard them and say Hank where are
the videos you preach video do some
yourself we want to see your videos get
going ok that would make me really happy
if you guys would do that the next one
is matures em
and this one is great one of my favorite
channels and we've partnered together to
work on the newest believe video that I
have on my channel right now he's got
some great motivational stuff and dude
is an artist he's got mad skills and I'm
honored to be able to work with him i
watch all the stuff that he puts out and
I'm an overall a huge fan if you want
motivation this is the channel to watch
he's one of the top three in the world
at what he does and you should just
check it out the next one is corporate
valley this one I don't watch all of
their stuff but some of them are
interesting I stumbled onto this channel
when I was looking for advice from
famous entrepreneurs I was trying to
collect famous entrepreneur stories and
how they got started what their nuggets
of wisdom would be for entrepreneurs and
they had a lot of those kinds of videos
they had a lot of CEO entrepreneurs I
contra MERS have started off and I've
become like CEOs of their business big
businesses so like Howard Schultz of
starbucks and Richard Branson from
virgin those kind of guys and had them
basically give their advice and so a lot
of that stuff is inspirational and a new
stuff being released all the time Gary
Vaynerchuk one of my favorite guys I
watch almost all the new stuff he comes
up with he is great and that he has
amazing ideas about social media and
building a brand and he's also real he's
honest he swears a lot so if you if you
mind that kind of thing you probably
shouldn't check out Gary Vaynerchuk but
he's real you know a lot of the people
who you watch they're not quite
comfortable in their own skin yet and it
takes takes a long time to develop you
know i'm still getting there especially
if you look at my first videos that they
were i was nervous and so you get more
comfortable over time but he is really
real he cuts through a lot of the BS
he's got some great ideas and and I
gonna watch everything that comes out of
his channel Jenny moon jenny is my media
coach and so she will help me with my
radio shows she'll help me with my
videos every week we have a call
Wednesday morning and we go over for an
hour the stuff that I've been working on
and she gives me feedback on how it can
make it better we skipped this more
iOS film on Wednesdays I like meeting
her before my I shoot because she gives
him great ideas and what to do we
skipped today because i was up til 415
in the morning and felt a little sick
waking up and like I gotta do all these
videos I'm pumped but I couldn't do that
the call with her so shout-out Jenny I
love you thank you for all the help she
doesn't produce that much in her channel
but she's getting better at it her whole
thing is about connecting so she will
teach you how to connect with people
because it's so important that you want
people to understand your message you
have to get them on an emotional level
you have to get them to feel you first
before they'll listen to you you have to
get them to have a feeling before
they'll take action and so she helps you
connect with people and that applies to
not only your business but also your
personal life and in the last one on
here is ET the hip hop preacher is eric
thomas love this guy every monday he's
got a new video that comes out called
thank God is Monday and it's
motivational stuff it's it's related to
being an entrepreneur but more just
getting up off your butt and doing work
and stop complaining and stop listening
to the the doubters in your life and you
are responsible for your life and he
always has a motivational inspirational
message that is uplifting empowering
inspiring and so I look forward to
Monday mornings and watching his stuff
and I shared the other guy who I watch a
lot of his stuff but it doesn't have a
channel as far as I know at least is
seth godin and he's got a lot of
keynotes a lot of speeches and he's got
a lot of great ideas he is easy to
relate to easy to understand a lot of
great books he focuses mostly I think
just on his blog so he doesn't have a
Twitter account he doesn't have a
youtube channel but I try to digest a
lot of his stuff because it changes how
you think as an entrepreneur and will
definitely give you some ideas so that's
what I watch on youtube and again I'm
consuming this every day and it's a big
part of what shapes the projects that
I'm working on and who I've become so I
thank everybody who I've just listed
thank you so much for your inspiration
and for your ongoing dedication a lot of
these guys they started just like me
with with nothing like you just
into a camera and you're doing it with
no feedback like nobody's liking it
nobody's commenting nobody's watching
and with time you get better and people
keep doing it they keep doing and I keep
doing it because I feel it's the right
thing to do and now I have traction and
now I have a mentor but when I started I
had nothing and so you know these are
the people I support if there's people
in your network people who you watch on
YouTube leave them a comment you know
just let them know that what they're
doing is important to you because that's
honestly the best part of my days when i
wake up and and i can look at the
comments that have come in on my youtube
videos and see all the other positive
things because it can be hard every day
to keep going and seeing that you're
having an impact on people's lives gives
you confidence and courage and
motivation to keep going so if there's
someone who you support like I support
these 8+1 people leave a comment let
them know let them know that they're
important because that means something I
can tell you that that really means
something to them believe thank you guys
for watching you liked the video give it
a thumbs up subscribe to the channel and
leave a comment you know how important
it is to me now please leave a comment
let me know what you think even it was
just hey love that video thanks to the
suggestions or if you have a question
I'll make a video response for you thank
you so much great question and I'll see
you soon